you've talked about how you use lucid
dreaming to think to come up with ideas
as a source of creativity because you
may be talk through that
maybe the process of how to you've
invented a lot of things you've came up
and thought through some very
interesting ideas
what advice would you give or can you
speak to the process of thinking
of how to think how to think creatively
well I mean sometimes I I will think
through in a dream and try to interpret
that but
I think the key issue that I would
tell younger people
um
is to put yourself in the position that
what you're trying to create already
exists
and then you're explaining like
how it works
exactly that's really interesting you
paint a world that you would like to
exist you think and exist
and reverse engineering and then you
actually imagine you're giving a speech
about how you created this well you'd
have to then work backwards as to how
how you would create it in order to make
it work that's brilliant and that
requires us some imagination to some
first principles thinking
you have to visualize that world that's
really interesting
and generally when I talk about things
we're trying to invent I would use the
present tense as if it already exists
not just to give myself that that
confidence but everybody else is working
on it
um we just have to kind of
uh do all the steps in order to make it
action actual how much of a good idea is
about timing
how much is it about your Genius versus
that its time has come
timing is very important I mean that's
really why I got into futurism I'm not I
didn't
I wasn't inherently a futurist
that there's not really my goal
uh that's really to to figure out when
things are feasible
we see that now with large-scale models
they're very large scale models like
gpt3
it started two years ago
four years ago it wasn't feasible in
fact they did create a GPT too
uh which didn't work
so it required a certain amount of
timing
having to do with this exponential
growth of of computing power
so futurism in some sense is a study of
timing
trying to understand how the world will
evolve yeah and when will the capacity
for certain ideas and that's become a
thing in itself and to try to time
things in the future
but really it's a original purpose was
to tie my products I mean I did OCR in
the 1970s
uh because those CRS
doesn't require a lot of computation
optical character recognition so we were
able to do that in the 70s
and I waited till the 80s to Address
speech recognition since it requires uh
more computation so you were thinking
through timing when you're developing
those things yeah has its time come
yeah
and that's how you've developed that
brain power to start to think in a
future sense when how will the world
look like
in 2045 and work backwards yeah and how
it gets there but that has become a
thing in itself because
looking at what uh things will be like
in the future
reflects such dramatic changes in in how
humans will live
uh that was worth communicating also so
you developed that
muscle of predicting the future and then
applied broadly and start to discuss how
it changes the world of technology how
it changes the world of human life
on Earth
in Danielle one of your books you write
about someone who has the courage to
question assumptions that limit human
imagination to solve problems and you
also give advice and
how each of us can have this kind of
um courage well it's good that you
picked that quote because I think that
that symbolize what Danielle is about
courage
so how can each of us have that courage
to Quest question assumptions
I mean we see that when people can
go beyond the current
round and create something that's new
I mean take Uber for example before that
existed you never thought that that
would be feasible and it did require
changes in the way people work
is there practical advice as you give in
the book about each what each of us can
do to be a Danielle
well she looks at the situation and
tries to imagine
uh
how she can overcome various obstacles
and then she goes for it
and she's a very good communicator so
she can communicate
these ideas to other people
and there's practical advice of learning
to program and recording your life
and things of this nature become a
physicist so you list a bunch of
different uh suggestions of how to throw
yourself into this world yeah I mean
it's kind of a
idea how young people can actually
Change the World by
learning all of these different
skills and at the core of that is the
belief that you can change the world
that your mind your body can change the
world yeah that's right
and not letting anyone else tell you
otherwise
it's very good exactly